und die verlassen war wirklich
vegetarisch macht man aus kichererbsen
ach ich liebe die orientalische küche
oder auch die sprache persisch was
machst du eigentlich sonst so lena
studierst du momentan job ich nur
nebenbei ich will schauspielerin werden
meine eltern finden das zwar
fürchterlich aber vorstellen
meine eltern wollten nicht dass ich in
deutschland studieren aber es war
einfach mein traum während du hast ihn
verwirklicht jetzt habe ich noch nicht
verwirklicht ich muss erst noch die
aufnahmeprüfung schaffen
wie wäre es wenn du als verwechslung
einkaufen gehen würdest dieser rechte zu
tun
das lässt man sich beschwert naja einen
kasten bier toast wurde und schützen das
nicht gerade die ernährung nicht vorzüge
nicht zu vergessen
ja aber bestellt hatte ich ein bio müsli
ist ja schon hier kommt wahrscheinlich
ist es einfach besser wenn ich selber
einkaufen gehen
lass deine bücher seien und bringen was
leckeres mehr kosten wie zum beispiel
vielen dank allein hätte ich nicht so
gerne zwei auch nur ein kleiner um
darf ich vorstellen das ist mein
mitbewohner reza und das ist meine neue
freundin lena hallo riesa
sein mitbewohner wachstum der umweg hat
sich ja gelohnt